welcome to Hannity an alarming new
report from the house Judiciary
Committee in 2021 believe it or not your
federal government began asking Banks to
sift through private transactions from
millions of Americans and search for
terms like Trump and Maga uh which so
which banks voluntarily handed over that
information and what did the doj do with
it now the house uh Judiciary Committee
chairman Jim Jordan will join us with
more on this orwellian and frankly
dangerous breach of personal privacy now
needless to say the 2024 election cannot
happen soon enough now thankfully we are
just six days away from the New
Hampshire primary now one important note
unlike many other primaries the granite
state allows Independents and Democrats
who register as Independents to
participate in the Republican race over
4,000 Democrats by the way they're now
independent they're going to want to
vote uh it looks like those votes are
being directed towards former Ambassador
Nikki Haley she's performing well among
those two groups expectations are high
but as of tonight Donald Trump maintains
a large lead in the state of New
Hampshire according to the latest Boston
Globe suffk University poll uh Trump is
up by 16 the Anam University poll just
came out Trump up by 13 now all of the
Republican candidates including Trump
they are outperforming Biden in general
election especially true in the key
Battleground States like Michigan
Arizona and Nevada now tonight a rare
Moment of clarity from the vice
president that's vice president Harris
Let's Take a Look are you scared first
of all what could happen if Trump ever
became God forbid president again and
what are you going to do to stop the
crazies I am scared as
heck yeah which is why I'm traveling our
country you know there's an old saying
that there are only two ways to run for
office either without an opponent or
scared so on all of those points yes we
should all be scared yeah but as we know
and certainly this is a a table of very
powerful
women we don't run away from something
when we're scared we fight back against
it maybe you should be scared about the
unvetted uh 10 million illegal
immigrants that your Administration is
allowing into the country maybe you
should be scared about war in Europe uh
and threats against NATO allies maybe
you should be scared about war in the
Middle East uh as you pressure Israel to
give up their fight against radical
terrorists uh that took place there uh
now she is right they should be Running
Scared the Biden Harris ticket now has
two colossal hurdles to overcome of
course Joe Biden well we all know it's
very obvious it's very clear he's just
not mentally competent and every day
America's oldest president keeps getting
worse right before our rides he needs
help walking he needs help talking the
first lady reportedly not only helping
him out stage left or stage right but
also helping him with his daily schedule
he gets up late goes to bed early takes
more vacations than any president in the
modern era we barely see him in public
holds almost no political rallies rarely
conducts press conferences or shows up
for a serious interview VI uh he does go
to Delaware an awful lot spends more
time on vacation than any other
president as I said in the modern era
naturally most people seem to view Biden
as president in name only and this
brings us to the second hurdle to
re-election whoever is running the show
at 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue they're
doing a terrible job are you better off
than you were four years ago their
decision making is historically bad
their policies result in one crisis
after another uh the American people you
can all see personally and feel this
rolling disaster every single day every
time you fill up at your gas station
every time you buy groceries every time
you go out to eat every time you order a
GrubHub you feel the impact of Biden
inflation every time you look for a new
house a new car or pay rent or open a
credit card bill you know the burden of
Biden nomics and every single time you
see illegal immigrants pouring into our
country unvetted enjoying taxpayer
funded housing Transportation education
and health care you should feel betrayed
because they're not enforcing the laws
he's not upholding his oath for our
Constitution and now uh a new palpable
fear World War III as violence and
Carnage overseas it gets worse and worse
and worse and you don't have to be a
Maga Super Fan to realize America is
simply not better off on under Biden
there's not a single thing I can point
to that is oh they they they implemented
a policy that's successful I can't think
a one the chairman the CEO of JP Morgan
Chase Jamie Diamond definitely not a
conservative he previously donated a
Democrats was closely linked to former
Obama insiders but now even Jamie
Diamond has a stark warning for the
Biden campaign take a look at this if
you look just take a step back be honest
he was kind of right about NATO kind of
right about immigration he grew the
economy quite
well tax reform worked he was right
about some of China I don't I don't like
what he did I said China virus he may
have been right and I don't like how he
said things about Mexico I don't like
but he wasn't wrong about so these
critical issues and that's why they're
voting for them the Democrats have done
a pretty good job with the deplorables
hugging onto their Bibles and their beer
and their guns I mean really I could we
just stop that stuff and actually grow
up and treat other people with respect
and listen to him a little bit and I do
think the economy will affect I think
this this negative talk about magga is
going to hurt Biden's election
campaign democracy in Peril January 6
Trump is Evil by the way president Trump
was right notice that diamon made those
remarks on CNBC he didn't even get push
back now it is increasingly difficult
for the media mob to do the heavy
lifting for Joe Biden but make no
mistake they will try their best and
according to a recent study look at this
from Syracuse only
3.4% of quote journalists most of them
are not journalists claim to be
Republicans the other
96% uh are likely either rooting against
Trump or actively working in conjunction
with the Democratic party they are
they're are an extension of the press
Office of the DNC and Joe Biden they
just don't hate Donald Trump they also
despise uh any American that supports
him and everyone that doesn't buy into
their twisted worldview and right on Q
you got both fake news CNN msdnc
refusing to take God forbid we hear from
uh the historic winner of Iowa and here
his speech in full Senator Marco Rubio
responded on uh X saying quote Us Media
refusing to carry Trump speech live last
night after a a historic Iowa Victory is
exactly how undemocratic regimes abroad
use state run media to try to
delegitimize dismiss discredit their
political opposition Democrats the mob
in the media no longer care about facts
they don't care about Logic the only
thing they seem to care about you know
is narrative and power and as George W
Orwell famously wrote quote whatever the
party uh holds to be the truth is the
truth you know it is impossible to see
reality except Looking Through The Eyes
Of The Party hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else